and now Chester a bum covers the massive
snowstorm in Chicago this is Jerry
bound for channel awesome heretofore
when did the biggest news story instead
Chicago's ever experienced please I
think it's weather Vegas I've been
really surprising they told you in Vegas
I'm not really sure why they have me out
here I guess they just want somebody to
cover the snow start there it is it's
cold and Sawadee done it's freezing my
nipples up hey yeah yeah I don't even
have a microphone it's just a marker
sharpie it's good reception hey I'm
gonna stay out here and keep you
informed about how things are going
what about out here again
still going God's dandruff will not let
up I could be me but it's actually
colder maybe even worse it's it's not
like those blizzards that you get a
Dairy Queen those who teaches this this
is not this is very cold and it hurts I
think I would hurt if I could feel my
fingers anymore which I cannot I eat my
toe to stay alive who's gonna ban that
don't you think anyway but maybe that
because I'm also feeling in my tongue
anyway we'll keep you updated once again
still cold
I never shall have the comfort of my box
and a nice fireplace going until it set
the Box on fire and now I have no place
to they begin but that's usual you might
be looking at my current residence right
now
what's wrong with you people wait where
are you still watching that I'm freezing
everything off I can't feel anything
like events nothing
are you sure I can't feel anything
either leads I thought I'd cut on the
outgoing drives with not everything but
now this is numb yes and the progress
okay am I gonna try and get by I'm sure
I'll be able to feel it you people are
sick
you're sexy people why don't you start
watching that's gonna calm down so I can
get somebody set me on fire I'd be
better than
well they wanted me to come out during
the night to cover it in case you're
wondering now I'm not standing sideways
the snow is going horizontally I guess
they wanted me to come out here to tell
you it anything has changed in the night
it's pretty much the city oh except for
one little different that's taller
God taking me and all your warmness are
not effects true guys it's Satan take me
Satan it must be so warm right now just
when you think there's nothing less that
you can't lose the feeling in there goes
your Johnson the chanson is gone is like
there's nothing there I know it's so
cold it's warm
oh what a shock gets even colder
ooh I have to say to do the lift of the
weather report inside a pier D a person
from across the street saw what I was
doing and considered it intolerable
cruelty so they invited me inside their
house and general awesome will be
looking forward to a how did he put it
lawsuit so I will tell you how the rest
of the storm is going uh let me just
check this it is still snowing it is
still snowing this is how most people
get through weather report well actually
not me D I don't have internet I just
frickin look outside I don't want some
people say about all of you yeah at
least I am inside right now with that
nifty horrible snow can not get to me